I'm going in the far side. Yeah. You're in the middle? No. We're in the middle. No, we go how we're in the middle. Because it's your guest. Oh, and there's talking couches.
Yes. Yes. No, let me go out for the thing. What does that mean? We just can mess it. When we walk out. Yeah. I'm going to go far.
I'm going to sit on the couch because it's my guest. Well, we can sit wherever you want. We can sit. Don't sit on the couch. No, we can sit. What doesn't matter? I've sat on the far side way too many times. OK.
No, I'm sitting on the far side now, and you're going to be sitting on the near side. By the way, I had a tie iced tea, and it is not settling. But is the tea is a caffeine giving you energy? Because I feel like I need a little bit of energy. I know it worked out well for me and boxing. That works. I'm going to show you how hard I want you to slap me.
OK, don't. OK. That worked. That, but don't, okay. That was for real. For real? Okay, here we go. I missed it entirely. Can you do the other side? Here we go.
Here we go. Here we go. Welcome to your here end. All new is Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish!
Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Smarlish! Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks.
Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks. Sharks.
Sharks. Sharks. A half a standing ovation. It's the greatest. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I think I have to beat Charles. Pete Charles, we beat each other for Rob Nader. Pete Soss, he got it. You guys, take a seat. So, Will's best friends get the best seat in the house.
No, no. Rob, it didn't pay a dollar, right? This is a very LA crowd because we have the four best seats right here just empty. Just empty. Oh. Hello, Los Angeles! Hey!
Hey! We, uh, thank you for coming. We finally made it home. We made it home. We've been on the road. Yeah. We've taken this stupid ass, incredibly underwhelming night. Yeah.
You guys are about to see on the road for a week. And we had a really, really good time. We want to keep setting the bars as low as possible for you all. So, let's get me to find out. So, we said let's sit down. Yeah, let's sit down. All right, so I'm on this side.
You're there. You're on that side. We did. We did. We got applause for sitting. applause for sitting. We legit slapped each other backstage and that was not rehearsed and it actually hurt.
Yeah, I put a little color in not rehearsed and it actually hurt. Yeah, I put a little color in my face though, and it's your face completely. But Sean, you got to heart out tonight, right? Because you got to get back to camp. Yeah, because you're dressed like a... LAUGHTER He's got his whistle in his pocket.
Yeah. And the other one is giving a high-fives. Oh, no. LAUGHTER You look very, very cute. I look very cute. You do look like, which is very scary for a 51-year-old. Yeah.
No, you look, it looks like this looks like Sunday afternoon at your house. Well, it's what we all do, kind of. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, by the way, I'm chewing gum. I'm sorry, and by the way, they ever put gum in water and it flavors the water. Wow. But how do you guys feel?
Are you guys tired from the tour? Are you pumped? Well, they, you guys give us energy. Yeah, we legit can't believe that you guys listen to the podcast. That's true. That's really been a mind-blower. So first of all, thank you for doing that because all we're doing as you can tell,
if we just talk to each other, the fact that people are somewhat interested in listening to that is a mind-blower, we do feel like since you can fast forward all the crap parts or just go to a different episode when you're listening to the podcast, here you're trapped. So we feel like we do have to juice it a little bit. So do you feel like people maybe double time, like double speed your questions?
They have to. Because that's a great, yeah. That's a really good, smart-less hack. I'm gonna give you guys a lot of smart-less hacks. They did laugh, and applaud, like, you know, exactly what you're talking about. I was trying to think of like a good LA story, like when I first moved here.
Oh, settle in, everybody. Oh. Somebody's prepped a little bit. So, I was just before I started. Does it involve the 101? Boy, traffic is terrible. Oh, God. No, let's just single up a spot on Sean and take front seat. No, I may have said the story before, but when I first moved here and I got Will and Grace, I went to a cashier.
Hold your hands. No, I didn't have two nickels rubbed together. I had no money. And the cast and the producers invited us out to a dinner. So I drove my Toyota Corolla, which had a hubcap missing and a window out with the plastic. Yeah, plastic and duct tape. Yes, absolutely, 100%.
Come on. I swear to God. And so I drove. Is that the car you drove from Chicago? Yes, it is. Yes, and it broke down in Colorado. And I paid some guy, I don't even know money to fix it. And it was still broke down.
A mechanic, hopefully. I don't know. And so, it's just some guy on the road. So I'm driving, I'm sorry. So I get to the restaurant extra early, because I'm so nervous about, you know, them seeing my car and my car and I'm broke and anyway. So I got there.
Oh, you were embarrassed about. I was embarrassed about my car because it was like, we pieced together with Scotch tape. So I got it, I got there, I went in and then before the dinner was over, I kind of left early so that I could get my car from the valet. And leave before they can see me. So I'm like, bye, everybody, oh my God, I'm so excited.
I come out to the valet and I'm standing there and then Jimmy Burrows, Debra, Megan, Eric, the producers, a couple of writers. And now we're all standing there and I'm like, oh my God. And so he pulls the car up and I was like, and it's like barely getting there. So the last sub-tap rolls off. Right, and I said to everybody, I said to the Valet,
I go, what did you do to my car? Oh my God. I said to the ballet, I go, what did you do to my car? LAUGHTER Oh my god. First of all, I was a Porsche, now it's not a Porsche anymore. Now, ironically, you did end up getting a Porsche when the show performed. Yes, everybody had Porsche on the show, right? Right, that's also embarrassing, but I also didn't have money
when they gave me a Porsche, I'm like, give me the fucking money, I don't want to need another car for. Yeah. But it was very, very kind of them. But when you were struggling, actor, and you did it. So you sold it, right? Absolutely, right away. Yeah.
I had to pay my rent. I had my rent. I had to pay my rent. Relax, it was a boxer. But the point is, it's true. Why did you drive it? Or did you sell it? I just, I read the details on that story years ago.
And that always stuck with me. I was like, oh, they give them porcises. Oh, did you drive it or did you know? I just I read the details on that story years ago. And that always stuck with me. Yeah. I was like, oh, they give them porcises. Oh, did they? Yeah. I know it seems knobby, but it's kind of true. Yeah.
What about your first time out here? Do you remember? Yeah, I was talking about today. I drove out here as well. I drove. I had an old... Did they not have planes back then? Yeah. No.
No. It was so funny. And from Toronto, you couldn't have a longer drive. No, no, I drove from New York, because I was living in New York. Oh, New York is much closer. Yeah, so it's much... Yeah.
In fact, it's further away. That's true. But yeah, I drove. I had this old Volvo station wagon and I we drove out here I don't know why we made a trip. I love a Volvo station wagon. Yeah, I right It was it was a real piece of shit and it had it had it arrested through on the bottom and you could see the road underneath Like like Fred Fred for the stone. Yeah, like for the stone. It was it was that bad But it was it was a ton of fun and then I drove back ended, I ended up driving Vex in New York a couple months later.
And same car. Same car in like 40 hours straight. And that's the way to do it. To stop is like, no, you blirry eyed, you gotta keep going. No, and then I had somebody else with me, and I would sleep in the back, and he would drive, and then we would sleep like this.
That's what it looked like, for Randy, yeah. And my car was packed to the end, and I would get into the passenger seat, and I would go down on the bucket, and would sleep on the thing because there was no room. There was no room. Show us how you sleep again, really quick. Yeah. Sure.
It's like that. What? Hang on. Yeah. What? Wait, you sleep more comfortably in a car if you get down into the footwell? Yes! Yes, because you can't sleep like a purple cat.
Sure you can. Yeah, I'm not a cow. How do you do it on a plane, guy? I go back, dude. You don't get on the floor on the plane? That would be so great if you got on the floor on the plane. I mean, it's not just in throw eccentric on a plane. You guys hear this story of the podcast?
We got to do it for a second. Do we already tell those who have it? They already know it. They already know it, you know? Yeah, but we let's embarrass them further. No, no, no, no. He deserves to be embarrassed about this. Just to throw a can't sleep with shirt on, right?
I mean, I'm sure a lot of people sleep without their shirt on, right? And he can't sleep without a shirt on, and he can't sleep without doing crunches before he goes to sleep. Right, right. I don't know this story. I don't know this story.
So we're flying to England, I think. So it's going to be topless for quite a stretch. Yeah. And he's all tatted up and he's up front and everything. Where people are wearing ties and stuff. And he just pops his shirt off. He does a perfunctory cover with a little tiny blanket or whatever.
But five minutes into that, that's gone. And it's just some tatted up freak who looks like Iggy Pop. She has passed out in the front. It's like really? I'm afraid I need to wipe everything down. I could never sleep with my shirt off. It's disgusting. That's right.
He's got a layer to protect him from the germs. He's got a layer of spray tan that actually keeps the germs. But you will get down on the floor well of a car and sleep. Those germs are okay. Absolutely. At 24 years old. Yeah. Oh my God.
Wow. Let's get a guest. Alright, let's get a guest out here. Let's get a guest out here. It's Jason's guest. So we don't know who is. And by the way, just in case people don't know, and we say it all the time, we legitimately
don't know who the other person's guess are. So we've had to jump through a lot of hoops on this tour to, like, not cross paths with the guests. Yeah, we had a great one. Never mind. Okay, go ahead. What? What?
What? There. Oh, no, Jason, it's okay. But I have not learned my lesson because when's the last time you guys met a real bullfighter? Oh, no, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I could have been so cruel. I would love that. I would love that.
I would love it too. I would have a thousand questions for that. I would love it too if we were going to cover this, but they don't want that to. To a backstage, you'd love it. Here we come. Our guest tonight is a force, a comedic fire hose. Right?
It's a good start, right? Not a bullfighter. Very no, very good. This man can't be contained. His energy and positivity is infectious, y'all. Philadelphia couldn't hold him New York seasoned him. And now, lucky for us, he's planted out here in LA, pumping out Project After Project for all of us to gobble up.
He's done tons of movies, TV shows released multiple comedy albums and specials. He's got 45 nominations from everything. We're emmies to Grammys. He's got a freaking video game, I think, somehow though. He's been nice enough to pull it over to the side, give us a little time for Chatton Giggle here on the Smiley's couch, gang!
Buckle up, it's the one and only Kevin Hart. Oh! Oh! Oh, my God. Woo! Oh, my God. I love you, man. I love you. Well.
Man, I can't wait. He only moved. Oh, that's good. Hello, hello, hello. Kevin Hart. It's so cool, Jack. Am I on? By the way, you know what that is? That's redemption.
That is redemption. That is an over-deliver. And I'm over-deliver. Check, check. Can you hear me? Yeah. Yeah, we got you. All right.
Wait. Well, before you... What? I just want you... I want you guys to lower your expectations because I've been drinking. So I just... Slow, lower them down.
That's fair, fair warning. It's the gallon. Whoa, wow. Is it really? Good for you. That's cool for you. Superbowl we get. It smells real good.
And then behind there is just a chest full of weed, right? It's a shit. It's good for you. We're not paying him for this. Is he mad? Yes, he's mad. Here we go. No, it's not.
What's your fucking problem? Yeah! She's fucking fast. This is his fourth gig today. He's in the bag. It's Shunzen Church of Blocking. Yeah, he's just... He really just... Wait.
He really is pushing me back. Get the fuck back. All right. By the way, I'm such a huge fan. You've been on my list to come on as well, but I can't believe Jason and Ab Jop. I'm a massive fan. Did he turn you down? He said OK. Absolutely. I'm a massive fan. Did he turn you down?
He said okay. Absolutely. I'm a big fan. I'm a big fan of Bateman. You know what? I didn't tell you what. I bum rush Kevin when we were doing we did a different stroke. Oh no not not you were doing different.
I had these different strokes. You did that to life. Yeah that's right. For our buddy Jimmy Kimmel does this. Why do you have to count? Whatever the hell it is. he doesn't know what the hell it is you don't know what he does we did it he does a pretty handsome talk show but he did it we do reduce of episodes
of sitcoms we did facts life you played Arnold on different strokes it was so killed it yes so I cornered him and you really didn't have a chance to say no, I apologize. No, you didn't corner me. Look, you're in the group of guys that don't ask for shit.
I feel like there's a certain amount of people in our business that don't ask, that when they do ask, it's like, yeah, I'll do it because they don't ask. So those people that don't ask normally have something that's good when they do ask. So, Bateman asked, and I'll be honest, I'll be honest, and this is only for you guys, I thought it was Ozark. I thought I was, I did, I swear to God. I swear to God, I thought it was a scene in Ozark. I can't, and I, I found out.
You know what we can do is we can make the light blue if you like. No, no, it's okay. I just found out just now this isn't Ozark when it was alive. It would be a very special dream sequence. Call him Marty for the rest. Let's just keep calling him Marty. Um, um, um, a payback is gonna be tough isn't it.
What are you gonna ask me to do? Uh, I don't know. Jason, here's the weird thing, man. You don't want me to do anything. Here one don't know. Jason, here's the weird thing, man. You don't want me to do anything. Here, one of those guys is talented, but then you're like, eh, like, you know, what are you? It's like, it's like, what are you? That's a...
What do you really want from them? Right? No, on a serious note, Jason Bateman, to me, is Hollywood royalty. That is finished. By the way. Yes, I agree. By the way, here's what I mean when I say that.
Hollywood royalty. That's a typical definition. Will falls in his category too. Sean. Well, I don't. Sean, I'm not sure what you. Shouldn't have pushed him, Sean. I know.
Shouldn't have pushed him. Sean, if you didn't push me, I would have done my research. But, all right. Hollywood royalty to me is people that work consistently, consistently without an agenda, people that do what they want, and have a good time in doing it. Royalty.
Royalty. That's fucking a little bit of a Royalty. Yes, but I'm saying that's why I respect that. Thank you. Congratulations, you guys. Thank you. Hey! Hey, you got nominated for an interviewer of the year
that should be good enough. Right? No. You guys, you guys, wait, you guys, you guys are the royalty. And I'm the jester. You are the best camp counselor out of all four of us. So he's not the guy responsible for blocking? No, he's the tonight's No. All right, well,
pound to you, buddy. I know what you do now. Fuck yeah. All right. Now, so this is this is very a foreign to us, but you have spent a lot of time in front of audiences doing stand-up, doing specials. Yeah. You had you played in front of 55,000 people? Yeah, don't forget to tell us. Thank you guys. This is intimate. This is nice. Yeah. It's a very nice intimate crowd, man.
This is what it's about. How? It's about connecting with the people. Yeah. Here's what blows my mind. Here's what blows my mind. By the way, I'm a huge shark tank fan. And I saw you on Shark Tank, and I was blown away.
Thank you, man. I had no idea. I mean, I knew you had a lot of fun. Is that black? What the fuck are you saying? Hey. What are you saying? Yeah, so what were you on charting for? Were you pitching something or judging?
No, no. The fuck is that? I'm not seeing the show. No, but I have a big start. He was a shark. He was a shark. He was a shark. He was a shark.
You were pitching like, I got an idea? I don't know. No, no, no, no, Jay. He was like Mark Cuban, but a guest show. You were pitching like, I got an idea? I don't know. No, no, no, no, Chase. He was like Mark Cuban, but a guest. Okay, but I'm Kevin Hart, bitch. But I got my new name. What, he, am I pitching an idea? What, hang on.
If I've got some great idea for the new swifter or something, I don't wanna fund that. I want Mark Cuban to fund that. So I'm gonna go on the show, I'm gonna pitch him. Regardless of what I got in the bank, I want to hit you. You got more. That's stupid, because you can just call Mark Cuban.
Yeah. If you go on massive television. If you go on massive television. I'm sure I've built an extra step there. That's right. But I always knew you had all these things going on, but I just didn't know at that extent. I mean, you have this huge successful company
that makes all of these projects and these things come to life. I just had no idea. And on top of that, you invest in tons of things. Some of them I do too. So we're kind of messed up. Yeah. It's a secret to the success. But I think building up a
platform and infrastructure with people that are so talented, so amazing, to help me execute things that I have a vision for, have become my priority in the business. And also identifying people, maybe that might need a little help for access, and you kind of grandfathered that maybe a little bit. You bring people into your company. I do, you know, I really do. I think it's no longer about me, it's not about my stars, it's not about where I am, it's not about helping others.
And the real benefit, it's true. Yeah, it's true. That's why I do this podcast to help these guys out. That's the way I do it. Good for you, well. Now, with all of that work though, do you, are you good about taking breaks, whether it be at home or like fun vacations?
What's your work? This, this is a break. I'm taking a break now. That said, I don't wanna do something good, right? Let me come. Yeah, yeah. And like, I have a problem in here.
I think it's a problem, right? Just get it, no, I'm joking. On some real shit like I have a tough time doing that have a tough time taking breaks I have a tough time really taking time to myself and that's what I'm working on So if I had to say a flaw a flaw is realizing that I need downtime Like just to take your foot off the gas a little bit Yeah, so Kevin we first met over 20 years ago. You were a stand-up. What? It's the truth.
It's true. It was true. And you were a stand-up, but you were just breaking through. Like, obviously, you didn't have the success that you have now. Walk us through a little bit those first, because I remember those first couple of years, you did that pilot with a bunch of our friends. And then that pilot didn't get picked up,
and then you seemed like you did a pilot every year. You'd always be at the up-fronts, which is where they sell the ads for new shows. For Tracy, yeah. You were always like, yeah, for Tracy. By the way, we had Tracy. You were at Tracy? Sean's sister.
We went to Wisconsin, and she came on stage, and it was fucking... All Front Row T-shirts said, I know Tracy or... He was talking rad, man. It was so rad. Because we thought she was fake. But anyway- And by the way, it didn't look half as dumb
as Sean makes you sound. No. Like, what are you doing? She was kind of more with it than you, dude. Yeah. I get it. And we will be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by 8Sleep.
Did you know that temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? When you wake up in the middle of the night or feel extra groggy in the morning, temperature is usually the one to blame. The pod cover by 8Sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet and will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. So for me, in our apartment, our thermostat is crazy. Like, there's one zone in our apartment, in our small apartment, that services three rooms, right? So it clicks on cold in the middle of the night, then it shuts off to then click
on cold for another room. And while it's cooling down in another room, it gets hot again. Anyway, the point is the temperature in my room here in New York in my apartment is whacked. And I got the pod cover by eight sleep and I'm sleeping like a king again. And I love the pod cover and I love that we're talking about it on the podcast. Thanks to the pods, sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights
in how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine or whatever it is, impact your sleep and overall health. Invest in the rest you deserve with the eight-sleep pod. Go to eightsleep.com slash smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8-Sleep. That's the best offer you'll find, but you must visit 8sleep.com slash smartless
for $150 off. 8-Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK select countries in the EU and Australia. I'm not afraid to tell you, we get support from Audible, okay? It's the home of storytelling. Now I'm not, you know, a great reader, okay? I've for a bunch of reasons that I'm not going to bore you with. But so this Audible, these people, they're on to something here, all right? I may not read, but I will listen. Now, you're going to discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series. You're going to find guided wellness programs with Audible. You're going to find theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities were
renowned experts and exciting new voices in audio. The audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while you're traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. All right? Now, for instance, this book, the Suttler Art of Not Giving A Fuck by Mark Manson, this is a potential key to life. It is the, you know, they talk about on the show, the sexy indifference, it is an obnoxious term,
but it's better said by Mark Manson here, or better heard on Audible. New members can try Audible for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500 500 that's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless. When we think of sports stories, we tend to think of tales of epic on the field glory.
But the new podcast Sports Explains the World brings you some of the wildest and most surprising sports stories you've never heard, like the teenager who wrote a fake Wikipedia page for a young athlete and then watched as a real team fell for his prank. Diving into his Wikipedia page we turn three career goals into 11, added 20 new assists for good measure. Figures that nobody would, should, have believed. And the mysterious secret of a US Olympic superstar killed at the peak of his career. Was it an accident?
Did the police screw up the investigation? It was also nebulous. Each week, Sports Explains the World goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports, and their impact on the world. Listen to sports explains the world, on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to sports explains the world early and ad-free on Wondery Plus. And now back to the show. Kevin, what was that like those first, I don't know, 10 years, because you were just,
you never stopped working and trying and doing shit and like going after it. I'll summarize it. I'll summarize it so that it doesn't take too long. Because we have Scott to go. Well, I know, I know, Sean. I'm gonna get you. I don't want to hold you up too long.
You know, everybody asks about the ambition of a guy that comes from nothing. And what you got to understand is if you come from nothing, then nothing is exactly that. So anything that adds up to something is a benefit. So when you keep getting a little bit of something, your ambition grows. When I got a little piece of Hollywood and I got a little piece of success. And a little piece of success was actually getting a flight landing in the room being there for me. That's a piece.
I kept adding those pieces together, which you realize is that, was actually getting a flight landing in the room being there for me. That's a piece. I kept adding those pieces together, and what you realized is that, oh, God, it's so much better than what I had. And if it ultimately goes back to where I was, but I was already there, there is no loss. I think about that all the time. You already know what the result is from growing up,
so why not try something and fail, and learn from it, because the fallback is already familiar to you. It's your 1,000% correct. I kind of just repeated what you said. Well, you did. You actually did. They do it to me all the time.
They cut what I say from five minutes down to about 30 seconds. Well, Jason, take it as a compliment. Take it as a compliment. Before will, you know me. You saw it real younger me. And when you talk about that environment that we were in, I mean, I was a kid. I was a kid and I knew nothing else. So you guys honestly acted as examples of what to do, what not to do, where to go, where not to go,
within that world of early entertainment. I got this great, we talked about it when I saw you back in December, I've got this great photo that's now at my house and I've like, Kevin, Seth Rogan, me, Amy, my aunt, I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the show. I'm gonna go back to the December. I've got this great photo that's now at my house and of like Kevin, Seth Rogen, me, Amy, my ex,
January Jones, Jason Siegel, Nick Stoller, Judd Appetow, in like January 2001. We were just hanging out because we had nowhere else to be. And it was so crazy. I guess who I was. Guess. No. Guess.
I'm not going to do it. Take a guess. You're not going to get me canceled tonight. Say it. Say it. I'm going to make it one more day. I've got questions I've gone over here. There's a cancel proof. All right, you passed that test.
All right. I'll get you another one. Can I guess you were the black one. There you go. He's gone. Yes. Yes. By the way, you're done, buddy.
Yes, you're done. You're done. That's right. Now, do your kids recognize and appreciate how hard you work? Are they, do they give it up or are they just like, Dad, like, do they have notes on your phone? No. My kids don't give a fuck about me, man.
My kids are the best kids with no knowledge of, my kids truly, and this is said humbly, my kids have no idea how successful I am. They don't get it. Like, I'm dad. I've seen my kids cry over some people and I've, it's, it's really made me angry. Like, they've met YouTube stars at TikTokers, full tears. Oh my God. Oh my God, Dad, do you know who that is off of TikTok?
And I was like, TikTok. That's like, punch to them, punch to the ribs. Well, what happens like you're driving down the street and you're driving by a big billboard with your face? They don't care. They don't care. They say, Dad, you could take a better picture than that. No, my kids are, I make sure my kids are grounded in understanding that that's my job.
So when I'm working, my kids come to my job. I make my kids work on my job. My kids act as PAs. They act as set assistants. they act as set assistants, they act as DA assistants or like lower in craft services. So I make them work. So my kids are here tonight, give me some coffee, would you? I make a word.
Are they, are they, with the exposure to the business and all that stuff? Are they, are they finding stuff on set that they're really interested in? Do they have the bug? Do they want to get it? My daughter has the bug, she definitely wants to, but I'm an advocate of being a kid, finishing being a kid,
and then let's pursue the adult dream. And that's not to say that that's for everybody, that's for me a mouth hole. And my daughter loves that idea. And because of what we've agreed to, when she's done with school, you get the full support and backing of what you took the time to learn.
I don't wanna embed them in something at a young age and prohibit them from getting a full extent of that life, like as a child, especially where we are, where we live. It's not the same as when I came up. So they understand that. And I think my daughter wants to do it bad. My daughter wants to be...
Well, Lauren, she wants to act. She wants to act. My daughter wants to act bad. How old is she? I do it at 16. Oh, great. 16 years old. So, Sean wants to act too.
Do you? Do you? Do you? Good for you. It's going to happen. It's going to happen. It's going to be tough after this canceling, because you got one coming.
You got to get back up. You think I forgot about that black time. I know Toyota still works. Yeah, exactly. My son wants to be a stuntman. Really? Yeah. What's the stuntman?
OK, now I hear that, and I immediately think that he's got like, he's strapped like you. That he's like a snake's under a shirt just like you. Are you guys working out together? Yeah, no. He doesn't have that. So I want to tell you that you're wrong with that assessment. So like, what's not to be creepy, but if you took all your clothes off right now, we're
looking at it. Oh, we're looking at... Again, not to be creepy, right? Not to be creepy, right? Yeah, right. You're basically in bodybuilder shape. Have done for a lot. And that's admirable.
That takes a lot of discipline. You got a great routine I'm assuming. Yeah, yeah. Here's a thing, man. It's all about the walk away to the bathroom. Right? If you're married every morning, you get up and you go to the bathroom, sometimes naked, sometimes
you're just shirt on, sometimes it's not. But that bathroom walk away is always viewed by your partner. And my mind... You're working out a lot on the back of yourself. I'm working on just in general. So, calves, buttocks, and calves, buttocks, back, and lads, all right? I'll let him finish, man.
You wanna know what a fucking life is? If you finish, man. You are knowing a fucking life, huh? If you walk to the bathroom and you hear subtly, ugh. It will destroy you. So in the back of my mind, I don't ever want to hear that. So when I walk away, I tiptoe, and I make sure that I don't hear my wife go.
Ugh. All right. Because that means that she's no longer happy with that. So it's all about keeping it in shape. When I walk away, I need you to know, that's what you just fucked. Like that's my, that's my take away, that's it.
So now, yeah, I'm just doing the math here. So, if you're walking away from, she's looking at your rear and she's saying, I just fucked that. Take that in I'm just doing the math. Wait a minute. Hold on exactly. Yeah, let's go back. I'm rolling. Let me push it out My my husband understands that good luck. Yeah Oh
I love I love a canceled checkmate all right by the way Oh. Oh. Oh. I love, I love a cancel checkmate. All right. By the way, he's off the gett. He's back up. He's no longer on the cancel meter. As back people, we've given him a pass. That's not right, right?
All right. Now, we've stuck, we've stumbled into a little bit of a segue to, I want one. I want one. I want to ask about this nickname, Chocolate Dropper. Yes. But there's a little bit of a segue to that, right? Well, I don't understand how Sean Sex Life is.
No, no, no. You walk in a way. Okay, now. By the way, the walking away thing I love, because you don't ever look behind you. You just walk away. Oh, you just got to walk away. Yeah, you don't have way, the walking away thing I love, because you don't ever look behind you. You just walk away. Oh, you just gotta walk away. Yeah, you don't have to look, you don't have to be like,
if you ever look back, that's not an insecurity. That's right. Yeah, you don't want to look back. How do you feel, Jason? How do you feel about Amanda's view when you walk away? You look back all the time. You're checking out. Do you walk backwards out?
I'm a little bit more of a moonwalk to the bathroom, so. But do you walk backwards just t-shirt and then your shirt cocking? I don't think Jason wears drawers. I think it's just a t-shirt, picking a ass out. Yeah, that's just like. That's how I picture it too.
This body showers with a t-shirt on. Winning the poo. Winning the poo is what I pitch you in. Yeah. Just like it is at and the honey. Yeah. But that's called shirt cocking when you're just a t-shirt and then the shirt cocking.
Wait, does anybody sleep naked? Do you sleep naked? I'm a naked sleeper. Do you? Yeah. Fuck yeah. Really? Would you keep ballers in clothes?
Oh no. Are we looking at keep ballers in clothes? Oh, no. Are we looking at your sleep outfit right now? Absolutely. 100%. Absolutely. I'm going 9-9 in between shows in this. Do it. By the way, do some favorite. Don't say 9-9.
What do you... What do you... Sean, what do you wear? Always the same thing. I wear shorts and a long sleeve loose shirt because Scotty leaves the air conditioning on it, like, what do you wear? Always the same thing. I wear shorts and a long sleeve, like loose shirt, because Scotty leaves the air conditioning on it, like, you know, 20 below. Okay, and what kind of shorts?
What shorts? I know. Yeah, because if you wear sweat when the air conditioning's on, and you wear sweat, and then the comforter, it's too hot. So it wears shorts with one leg and one leg out. And then, and then a long sleeve, so you don't have to have the cover on you. It acts as the cover.
Is the one leg out to balance the spinning? Absolutely. What kind of shorts? Are we talking like a thick short? Are we like a flannel short, just because to really maximize, don't look at me like that. Yeah, yeah, what do you mean? What do you mean?
In a one area where your ass needs to be clean, you sweating it out. You gotta, you gotta flannel short. That's a, you got a flat-o-short. It's too cold to sweat anywhere. Bullshit, that's a flat-o-short. Under a fucking duvet, with a cover, you stink. Well, you fucking stink. You know what?
No, you stain your sheets. Sleeping naked. By the way, by the way, good point, which is why we we going black? Black sheets? I thought about that, Sean. I thought about that. Sean, we just got recanceled.
It's right canceled. Yeah, I'm back on top, bitch. Anybody who sleeps naked, you're staining your sheets from getting up in the middle of the night and going pee. That's the only thing that's... You're not saying you don't shout. There's a couple drops there. So you're going to have to change your sheets more often. Next question, chocolate drop.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, that is. Who's standing in your sheets? Who's standing in your sheets? Are you keep, love? No, no. Hold on, no, no, he's talking to you. I say, who is Dick is still dripping with my glasses?
What are you? What are you doing? I'm saying, you don't shake it off enough. Oh my God. I don't have to worry about that because I wear shorts. So wait, Kevin, I don't know if you know this. Jason! Jay-C.
Just in case. Jason back in the day, he would do this thing for a while where he wasn't wearing underwear. When we were years ago shooting a rest of the bell, and this is... Ha ha ha. I think we've told this. I went, I went, I went through a three,
I had a three year window where I went commando for some weird reason. So it happened, it happened, it's not that great. And I, and I, and it happened to be while I was working on a show where I wore nothing but khaki pants. So... So he would go to the bathroom, and then what he would do is he's worried about drippage. Oh, good. So...
Because you're going to go to the bathroom while we're ready to shoot. But I'm peeing, and so the cameras are going to be rolling. So guess what? I asked before I came here, I said, this is going to be some white boy shit that said no. I asked. Wait.
I'm fucking asked. I asked. So he goes, so one day, one day, we're on set. And Jason goes up by one of those, one of the huge garbage cans, and he's standing there,
and he takes paper, like toilet paper out of his pants, and goes, what are you doing, goes, I gotta put it in there to blot it for like 20 minutes. I gotta wrap it. You wrap it. And then he takes it out in the middle of the set. I'm like, what the fuck are you talking?
That's what serial killers do. I wanna ask, I wanna ask the honest question. I wanna ask the honest question, because I understand the world of producing. I'm gonna get back to the original question. I'm gonna ask the honest question because I understand the world of producing. I'm gonna get back to the original question. So you got to edit point. But before I get there, before I get there,
is there ever a good reaction like from the guy that doesn't wear draws? Like what? Like the man that doesn't wear underwear, he pulls out of underwear as a woman ever said, oh, no, I don't. No underwear. Like, what do you think that did?
I don't remember what prompted the... How lazy are you? Like, to not... By the way, it's horrible. It's horrible wearing no underwear. It's horrible wearing boxers. I think boxers, like, they don't bend. They don't stretch.
So I found boxer briefs. Have you guys heard about these boxes? Yes. I don't know. Fantastic. They're incredible. Now, what do you say you sleep naked? Yeah, and you got the onesie.
Yes, right. You're naked. But bald. But bald naked. But bald. How do you, how do you, we're gonna, we're gonna wrap up all this crap talk, but. I gave you a cup of wine.
Do you, do you, pee sitting down? Almost punched you in the fucking face, just then. No. I do. You pee sitting down, right? You're not, see, you're not old enough yet. How old, how old are you? I'm 42. Okay, you're not old enough yet. How old are you? I'm 42.
Okay, you're not old enough yet. You, you're peace sitting down, right? Well, I, well, you better not. I don't. I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, you fucking stutter. No. You stutter. You peace sitting down.
I've been through this for ten. I've been sitting down for years because I think it's rude when like somebody comes over here, like a guy's coming over here, I was like whatever, and they pee and it splashes, and they don't clean it up. So, you know what, guys, just sit down. It takes care of all the splashes. Yeah.
Yeah. There he is. Uh-oh. And it stretches out your back. Yeah. Your back's gonna start getting tight on you at about 50. And you just say, No, I was gonna make sure I heard it.
You missed her, you missed her, mate. I know, I fucking heard you. I fucking heard her. You just said so it doesn't splash all around. Yeah, I just sit down. Because a lot of guys are like, I don't fucking care, and then it's just like, and then they walk away.
So whoever comes out of my house, I always say, hey, please be neat and wipe the seat. Wait, is there a sign? Do you have a sign? No, but that's a good idea. Ha-ha-ha. All right, come on. All right, wipe the seat. Wait, is there a sign? Do you have a sign? No, but that's a good idea. Ha-ha-ha. All right, come on. All right, so all right, we're out of the bathroom.
We're out of the bedroom. Hang on. All right, let's get out of the bathroom out of the bedroom. Let's get to the shoe store. Shoesalesman, take me to the shoesalesman days. Oh, back on. No, really? I'm really going to get my ass kicked now.
I'm going to try. I'm going to try. Because he said, wait, what about, what about? Yeah, I'll let it go. I'll let it fucking go really gonna go back to his kick now. I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die because he said, Wait, what about, what about, I'm gonna let it go. I'll let it fucking go, but I don't like you saying that we're all nasty and pee on the seat. I've never peed on the fuck to see. He's got good hair. I'm not saying, I'm not saying all of it.
He's got better hair. He's very racist, what he said. He suggested a black people, whatever. All right, let's go. So, will, will, will, had some interesting jobs. Sean's had some interesting jobs. It's had some interesting jobs. They'll hear she's Sailsing she's salesman. What is in your quiver? She's salesman is definitely what I was who I used to be. How long?
I was a shoesman. She's has been for probably two years. Yeah. I'm very good. I mean We selling sneakers. We sell dress shoes. I saw everything. Yeah. Hasn't had Has that experience made you in your, all your tentacles in your business want to do something with shoes? Because that didn't really. What I want you to do is show. Wait a second, what was that question? Did you say tentacles, what?
No, like, with all your businesses going on, I know you probably, you may already have this. You're unthink fuckin' nice, John. It's gonna be tonight and it's gonna be dear diary. Kevin Hart scares the shit out of me. I know. I know. You want to know if he's got a desire to make you guess.
What did you say? I meant like all your business tend to close. All the businesses that you have going, did your experience being a shoe salesman want to start your own line of shoes? Oh, so you... He's got Sandy. You want to know if all my success within business
and endeavors, at some point, if I was like, this should be shoes. He's going to beat your ass. Yeah. Like, heaven-hard shoes. Yeah, got it. That you can pee on. Got it, got it. Maybe the rubber boots. I don't know. Not a white.
Not a white. Sean has grown on me more and more. I know. Here's a shoe salesman, Tiffany. Shoes salesman showed me the importance of like charisma, charm, right? And in the world of selling shoes, you got a commission of what you sow.
I mean, money off of being personable and getting people to come back. Oh, God, I can do this. And by the way, I did it because I've really learned about it. So I didn't have acid, I didn't bullshit it, but I didn't think you want to know about a sneaker. Sean, you got a flat foot. That's a flat sneaker.
Bad away, no polythene, or no, actually, actually you do. There's a loo-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-'s all what they were. Pro-Native Sub-Native, no way your foot roll was Jason. I'm just qualified. But yeah, I got it right. Granddad's got orthotics in here. Don't worry about that. Your foot's dead. I do too. So, foot.
That's a dead foot. My left toe has been numb for years. But, but you're saying something there, which you, there was a challenge to figure out the customer to see who you needed to be to get the commission that you wanted. It's kind of like acting, kind of changing into the part that job, that job made me realize, oh God,
there's something about me that gets people to do the thing that I want. Right. And when I decided to leave that job and pursue the thing that I wanted to do, the person that I had to get to do, the things that my customers were doing with my mom. How do I get my mom to believe in the thing
that I want to do? So the same way I got the customers to believe that this is a shoe for them, I have to take that same cadence, that same quality, give it to my mom. Once I got my mom to believe that thing, oh my God, I'm winning, half the battle is done. My mom believes in me.
She supports me, but now how do I make money? Now I had to convince the comedy clubs. I can do the thing that I said I would do. Was she, was she, when you said you wanted to be a comic, was she, am I understanding you correctly? She was like, wait, come on, Kevin, really? I mean, no parent-aut the gate is supportive of the, good, you want to be a stand-up, yeah?
You know, like, not when you have a different lane as laid out for you, so it was one of convincing. Who were you writing jokes? Like, when you were selling shoes, you were like, already thinking about you wanted to get into comedy, you wanted to be a stand-up, were you writing jokes, were you thinking in that way already? I have never written a joke in my life.
I've never written a joke word for word. At that point, I had funny stuff that I wanted to talk about. Stories that you could shape and yeah. I had stuff. I'm a person that shapes and molds stuff. Who made you laugh the hardest growing up? That's so funny. In your family, what was your mom?
I was gonna say it's not a comic. My dad. Yeah? Not because he was funny, but because he In your family, what you was, you're like, oh, I was gonna say it's not a comic, my dad. Yeah, my dad. Not because he was funny, but because he was so ignorant to what he was doing. My dad had no idea the damage that he calls by giving himself. But it made you laugh like hell.
It was the funniest thing that ever happened. Look at this stupid motherfucker. No, you didn't think he was stupid. He was just like, I can't believe you said that. Like, my dad, there was a relative that died. My mom's sister, and this is dark, but I'm gonna tell you anyway. My mom's sister died, and we go to the funeral,
my dad comes to the funeral, and it's myself, and my mom's other sisters in a circle. My dad comes up in his first words. He was like, we dropping like flies, ain't we? And everybody looked around. He was like, shot his whole brain next, got down. And nobody could say anything, but it was so bad, because they didn't even like him. They didn't like my dad.
He suggested the information as if he was a fan favorite. And he had all, like, and it was a funeral. My dad showed up in, like, white linen at a funeral. He's one of a kind, but I can say for me, that guy, he made me understand humor. Humor sometimes is subjective. My dad has always been subjective. Nobody's ever really liked his approach,
but that's the side that I gravitated towards. And that's what's in me. We'll be right back. In the first part of the 20th century, the Hilton family had a lock on the hotel industry by offering upscaled service at a modest price. The company was expanding fast and buying up iconic properties across the country like the Plaza and the Waldorf Astoria, but their unchallenged rise wouldn't last.
An ambitious Mormon named JW Marriott decides to pivot from restaurants to hospitality, and he's after Hilton's business, developing modern hotels across the world, but both the Hilton and Marriott families will have to contend with their share of drama in finding a successor, while also fighting to stay solvent in a high stakes business. Hi, I'm David Brown, the host of Wondery's Show Business Wars. We go deep into some of the biggest corporate rivalries of all time. In our latest season, Hilton and Merriott are in a race to expand globally and secure the loyalty of fickle customers.
Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. And back to the show. What was that first time, what was that first time you went on stage and did stand up? What was the venue, what was, do you remember that like, Life House Comedy Club, six people, six people, six.
Six. Wait, what? Life House Comedy Club show, you fucking heard me. Life House Comedy Club. I people. Six. Six. Wait, what? Laugh House Comedy Club showing you fucking heard me. Laugh House Comedy Club. I can love it. Laugh House Comedy Club. Six people. Six people.
Wow. After God damn comedy club, I go up, I do jokes. They're not laughing, but they're listening. But what I fell in love with was not the people and not the response, but the light. The light didn't deter me. And that's where people buckle. People buckle at the light.
You talking about the spot? I'm talking about the spot. No, Jason, I'm talking about the fucking light bomb. I'm the top. Yeah, the spotlight. Yes. The spotlight. That is my kryptonite.
This is nerve wracking. Being on a stage with a spotlight, I think there isn't one on us. Makes me, I just freeze. No, that's a spotlight. That's an egg crate. It's a 50 by 50. No, it's a modern day spotlight.
What are you talking about? This is a spotlight. You guys got it up. You said something right now. Everybody's going to get quietly going to listen. Some people freeze, some people don't. Those that don't win, I did not freeze. And granted, I did not get a laugh that night.
I kept going. And that's what was, that was the thing for me. That was the bug that bit me. And I was like, this is what I want to do. Did you ever have just a wipe out, like a terrible stand-up night? That almost got you to say maybe not? Absolutely. Famous story.
I've told it several times, but I'll tell it again. No, it was. Well, it's new to you, it several times, but I'll tell it again. No, it's new to you, that's what I said I'll tell it again. Thank you, my friend. Um. Um. Uh, I'm in a learning city. I'm doing a joke, and I remember doing a joke
and the guy stood up and he was like, yes, no, shut the fuck up. Uh-oh. I thought Buffalo Wing got me. Oh my God. By the way, I've never seen accuracy like this in my life. Buffalo Wing hits me. It's me. We're in the face. Little bit of sauce. this in my life. Buffalo wing hits me.
It's me. We're in the face. Little bit of sauce. Get to my eye. Not a lot. Enough to give me a problem where I can't see. I'm like, all right, that's enough. I'm a man first.
Don't disrespect me. He's like, that's enough. We had enough of you. Get off the stage. Get the fuck off the stage. I'm like, no, I'm going to finish my jokes. And I go to finish my jokes. And the whole crowd, like, oh, no. We don't want you to finish. They were like, boo, I'm gonna finish my jokes. And I go to finish my jokes and the whole crowd,
like, oh, no, we don't want you to finish. They were like, boo, boo, boo. I got booed. Some other comments were back there. They shook my hand and they're like, yo, you gonna be all right. I was like, yeah, I'll be back next week. They're all playing. I came back next week, same crowd.
I tried to revamp my set the best I could. I go up, I perform. I didn't get booed. I didn't necessarily get big laughs, but I survived this set. And I was the biggest win for me in my life because I came back to the place that's destroying me. So all of my wins, all of my wins in the beginning,
I don't have hero stories. I don't have, oh my god, and they stood up and carried me out. I don't have those stories. All of my wins were mental wins. And a mental wins came from where I come from, where I come from, you beat each other up, we tear each other down, and we destroy the confidence that some don't have.
So to survive that, we'll put you in a place of fucking good. Being that I got out of that, I was able to truly grow and really fall into a place where my family got to blossom. And comedy became realistic because I made my city give me a chance. It didn't give it to me. I made them give it to me.
Is there something that legitimately gives you fear? Is it like the health of your family or mortality or, for me, it's bees. Um, I mean, like, is there something that you're just like, that's always gonna be a pet fear of mine that's actually beneficial to you, that keeps you doing what you're doing and doing it well? I think the real fear right now is,
is fucking up what's close to being real. You know, I got an opportunity to create generational wealth. I got an opportunity to create and break ground that has yet to be broken for me and mine. For where I come from, you're part of a story that can amplify and propel different types of, I guess you're gonna say like what, and realistic approach to what a dream can really become.
I'm a part of that. So not accomplishing said goals or not finishing the story, it's not about me, it's about the people that are now are looking at me and oh my God, that's how you do it. So if I don't finish the thing that people are watching that I know I can do, I leave a story incomplete. And success to some is not success to me. It's really giving a true, clear, visual
into what wealth can be for where I come from, and it doesn't exist. So the fear is that. The fear is not completing that task. Well, and I will say, and I don't mean to embarrass you, but you seem to be doing it in such a graceful, classy kind way. There you have a quality that is so infectious with your vulnerability or humanity.
But like, you're not afraid to make a jackass out of yourself. You're never, you're never posturing, you're never playing cool, you're not afraid to be the butt of a joke, and it's so winning, and it's so fun to follow, and get behind, and it's like, I mean, I'd watch you read the phone book. It's just, yeah. I appreciate it.
I appreciate it. I appreciate it. Um, it's, I think the dope thing about where we are, and I do say we Well, kind of right. Oh, thank you. Come on, man. Thank you, right? Yeah, me and you you already know where we sit That's right. I think cancer you you then cancel me. All right, we're back on track I Think the dope thing about where we sit is, you know, in this business, we've been putting the position for a long time and believe that we will work for higher.
And those that have hired us as amazing and dope as those opportunities are and will continue to be, that's all we knew that exists. And now, you know, you're looking in the new era where we can control, we can create, we can do, it's create, we can do. It's different, it's a different agenda. And we're supposed to progress. We're supposed to grow. And the relationships we see in us and our partners
are supposed to be coming exactly that partnerships. And when you see that happening, it's, well, how do you become a part of the thing that's the biggest picture? How do you do that? And create opportunities for people to do that. It's like a springboard. So that's the priority for me.
It's no longer about me. I'm not going to be a bigger star. And I know it sounds like, be a bigger star. I'm not. No, you're at the top of the screen. Yes, it's what it is. Yeah. So for me, it's how do I, and I say that humbly, by the way,
I'm not. I say, how do I fucking create the opportunity for the next versions to be bigger, to be better? That's the new priority. And if you don't find energy and a new thing, then you sit in the old thing. You get tired in the old thing. You get lazy in the old thing.
I don't want the old thing. Do you see, like, is there a moment for you in the future where you see that you've reached enough success or a certain goal where you're like, you know what, I'm good now I can kind of slow down. And we touched on that before. But is there something, is there a goal in mind where like if I can reach that,
I can maybe settle down and calm down a little bit? I think that there definitely is. But I think that for me, that will be very selfish knowing my background. If I go I'm done, I tap out, and I'm just gonna ride out and be good when I have the opportunity to create other opportunities, I think I'm doing a disservice to those
that need a service. So I will much rather, I will much rather provide the Olive Branch where I can. And look, if it happens, and that olive branch is great, and people come and they go through, they go, I did some dope shit, if they don't, at least I tried, and I can say,
that I gave an opportunity for a bigger conversation to be attached to the success outside of me. And that's when she started to struggle with, right? Like, you make money, you get big, you get grown, then you get to go and, oh, wait, well, what else? What else is important? Because it can't just be fame. Is there somebody that inspired you to think this way?
To be this what your mom. Rest in peace. My mom. Yeah. My mom was always, my mom is a you second those first. And my mom was always always, it's so sad when you look at the people around a person that's happy and those people are unhappy. They're unhappy because a person's happiness is solo.
How does your happiness, how do you spread it out? What are you doing to give that thing out? Where's your energy go? How are you truly implementing it into the lives of others? And it's a conversation that we don't have enough, right? As people, we're very selfish. We're very selfish at times within what we have and what we want to give.
I don't think that that's right. I think that if I have a high level of happy, if I have a high level of good or information, it's my fucking job to try to give it to those that can benefit off of you. That's my job. Yeah. Right?
And I think that people don't key in on that enough that they don't know that actually that is the key to happiness is giving it away. And I don't necessarily assure, but your energy and whatever that is that you have, if you, whatever you put out is what you're gonna get back and that may seem like, well, that's not altruistic because you're just doing it to get a result,
but you will get such joy if you constantly put that out to other people and make people feel good, you'll end up feeling, and that's the, that's something that I think that people really sleep on. They're not sleep on it, but if you really go and look at some of the, if you go and look at some of the most celebrated, the most celebrated happiest people, right, of our time or before our time, you'll look at their life, they struggle a lot.
The things that you think they had, they didn't have, but what they found joy in was providing. Providing it for others people find joy in seeing other people fucking glow and and what we've lost We've lost that so if you look at where we are now This is where battle amongst people because we're trying to control one another We're not allowing each other to fucking flourish and benefit of being who you are We're trying to make you what we want you to be, who we want you to be. I am a fan of joy. I'm a fan of smile, I'm a fan of happy,
I'm a fan of love, I always have been. That's what I'm a fan of. So if it's not that, for me, it doesn't work. I tried stand up once, and thank you, thank you. Thank you for asking. And my opening line was, I think I said this on the podcast, my opening joke was, you know, they say ballet is one of the most difficult things you can do, so I say, don't do it.
Well, we just learn. Wow. And we just learn. We just learn sometimes careers can last one joke. Well, I was going to say that. I mean, if we're being real, I'm still waiting for the joke. Well, Sean just showed his white and make it. No, no, there's a lot of different things.
Yeah, this is why I'm royalty. So you're not going to pack up and retire anytime soon. I'm not retiring. Not before your 50. Not before your 50. No, OK. Are you going to squeeze in any more of these great movies of Dwayne Johnson before then?
Yes. Because it's been really awesome. Now, you guys as close as it seems, because the chemistry is just awesome. You guys think this relationship is so great? My back hurts. Ah! Carry on that guy.
It's tough hurrying that big motherfucker to the finish line is tough. I can be honest with you, DJ and I are very close. That's a really good friend of mine. And our chemistry on screen is the same as off screen. And that's why we've won. We don't go into our trailers in between shots. We're on set, we're on set, and when we work together,
we truly do work together. And I love the fact that it's been far a few in between because we got something. And we saw each other, we just did a, we got animation movie coming out. With the DC, it's the Superpets. And it's snowballing that? No, it's not snowballing. By the like, can I have some more snowball please?
By the way, snowballs come but this is a different pet. I want to talk about snowball now because I got to talk about the other pet By the way, maybe the same voice. I'm not confident What I love though is that like we got together we talked man, and we were like We we just got to figure out the next one. But we both know it's never gonna be duplicated. You don't get that thing a lot. And we're very fortunate to have had the opportunity to make the movies that we have. And it must be dope. It must be nice that you've got somebody you're so close with that your escalation in your careers have been very, very, very similar. And you have someone to talk to about what's great about it, what's challenging about it,
what's how you're adjusting mentally, spiritually, all of that stuff. I can tell you what though, he's a lot more, DJ's much more grounded. And he's more concrete than I am. Well, because I'm in the shit. I'm in the shit. What are we, I'm in the shit, man. What is that, man? Well, I'm touring, I'm out all the time.
I'm on the road, off the road. I got the people, I'm dealing with, they're saying he's soft. You're saying he's a diva. No, I'm saying people I'm dealing with. I'm saying he's soft. You're saying he's a diva. No, I'm saying I'm more hands on into the world and more interactive with people on every day. He is from his company side and all of his ventures. But the live entertainment aspect, he's removed from.
So remember, the world when he was in wrestling and live performing, that's a different energy. You're given a different energy to people every day. You gotta be on. You gotta be fucking on. He would get off of a wrestler match and then rock, do the things, gotta do the eyebrow. He's gotta take a picture, right?
Like, I mean, that's me. And then he's gotta eat like 40 chickens a day or something. No, it's like, like, I was like, we were like, and the rocks knew men, you know? Okay, let's hear it, you know? And he's like, it's 30 stakes. I think he's done a great job. He's done a great job at like, you know,
cutting that side off, vituring into his new side. And DJ to business guys is a good dude. And that dude is flourishing. I'm still a little old. He's a sweet guy too. He said the sweet guy. He's a dickhead.
He's a dickhead. He's a dickhead. He's not a dickhead. I just want to be on the right. I want him to know that I said he was a sweet guy. Because he's a big dude, as we know. You know, you're doing something like we're doing here. You got a podcast comedy, Goldmines as well.
Yes, now, yeah, yeah. Now, is it like a chat show about with comics and talking about comedy and stand up? I do all organic, authentic conversation, right? What are conservatives whatsoever? And I challenge Jason. And I challenge you to do the same thing too. You know, you have to say just like us. You don't need these to you.
Well, no. You shouldn't have those, right? Because there's a beauty in the unknown. Mostly just a bounce from my bags. Right, well I get it. I get it. Whether you need them. Whether you need them or not.
Whether you need them or not. What I love to do, I love to actually discover, like I like the fact that I don't know. And when I don't know, I'm gonna ask. And the person has to answer the questions. So as comedians, comedians are dark. Some aren't. Some really have other issues, but you've never heard it.
And the people that you think you love, you really don't know. So on comedy, go mine, you got an opportunity to dive into the minds. Some of your favorite humorous fucking individuals and they say shit to you never thought they would say. Why? Because we have talks and conversations
that take some of the directions that you never thought that we would go. In conversations in general, that's what we're missing. So, organic, real, driven, transparency, I think that's what people need to see. You need to get back to seeing people be humans and not be programs. So, on comedy goldmines, comedians are actually fucking humans. How often are you doing it? I'm beyond it Jason, whenever I have time. I'm pretty fucking busy, man.
You know the schedule keeps changing, buddy. We got nothing. We're going this all the time. Yeah, you know what? We're even traveled with it. Kevin, you know what I love though? You know I love about you. You talk about you're doing all these things But you know at the root of it, you're still the same guy that you were 20 years ago. You have not changed. You're busier, you got more stuff, you had a lot more free time back then, but you're the same dude, and you have that same perspective, that's so, so refreshing.
That's gotta be the biggest win for you. I think so, and I hope that people that know me, well, I wanna say, I hope, I know, people that know me know that. I think from the outside, the perception is always gonna be different. Like, for example, I've got fucking glasses on now. And I'm gonna be honest with you, I know I look like a dick,
but if I take these off, it's been a, it's been a, it's been a, it's been a, a couple long days. Yes. It's been some long days and I know these eyes are dripping as I'm talking. That's why I'm blocking them. But I think the most, the most important thing for me is, I'm so fucking genuine. Like, I'm so good to the people that know me.
I really am who I say I am. And when I tell you, like Jason, when he say, Kav, you want to do it, I said, absolutely. It was very fast. It was very fast. I didn't even vet it out. By the way, this could've been some freaky shit. I don't know what to tell.
But I didn't vet it out because I'm like, I like to do. I know where it comes from. I remember when we did X, Y, and Z together on Simpson's Solutions. We talked, Jason, you never asked me for nothing. I'm there. That's truly who I am.
But it's one. It's just one favor. That's it. Yeah. No, no, no, because this wasn't a bad one. Like, you guys got a good thing going here. You got a great thing. Actually, you have a fantastic thing. You got a fucking crowd full of people that are supporting you guys.
Well, you made it real, real good tonight, and we cannot thank you enough, buddy. And really close you. So go, go. So come in the heart. Thank you, pal. Buddy, thank you, my friend. Thank you, boss. Sorry. Oh my god. Thank you.
Thank you, boss. Sorry. Oh my god. Oh my god. Thank you, boss. Oh my god. Oh my god. Thank you.
Thank you. Wow. He, uh, he, he did not look back as he was walking away. No, I know. He did not look back. He's confident. Yeah, he's confident. No, I'm not. By the way, great get. Great know. He did not look back. He's confident. He's confident. No, not that way.
By the way, great get. Great get. I'm a huge fan. How great was Kevin Kevin? I was going to come in hard. Yeah. He, you know, I meant that what I said, you know, a lot of people get into like a lot of actors are like,
oh, how do I... I love you. I love you. I love you. They love you. We love him too. What about these guys? No, I said, yeah? Yeah, that's okay.
Woo! It's okay. I let you know, a lot of... We don't need love. A lot of actors. It's my mother and my sister. Say, stand up. A lot of actors, you know, try...
There it is. No, that doesn't matter. Yeah! I love you too. All right, so coming up. No, no matter, no matter. Yeah. I love you, too. All right, so coming up. So a lot of actors, you know, try to get it. A lot of actors try to get into other facets of the business
because you realize you have to diversify. And he's such a huge inspiration to so many people who are just like maybe stuck just doing one thing as neck. Like, how can I follow Kevin Hart, man? Everything read up on him. How he did it is just so inspiring it's amazing to me yeah it's incredible and and I meant it that he is quite quite literally just the same dude he's so he's got his feet on the ground and he's of course he's just flying at such a different altitude now but but but maintaining that sort of that same sense of himself is pretty good. He's got
all this still and he's does all that. He's just got time to work out. I mean, he's huge. He's like, he's almost like he's... Bye, all of it! Woo! Bye, bye, bye, you smart. Hi, you smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Flush. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barberco. Smart. Last. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.